marikar said he joins me here on the
show mr. Mehra thanks for joining me I
appreciate it um let me ask you if
cursory right here why did you want the
Olympics in LA you know I think Olympics
are in our blood
I'm an 84 boy who grew up as a kid when
the world came to my town watch Carl
Lewis and Jones annoyed and Oscar De La
Hoya and everybody who in 1984 kind of
showed off the best of the city and made
a profit that we put into youth sports
that discovered people like the Williams
sisters so you know I think that unlike
a lot of places we've got infrastructure
built here it's a private bid no public
money we make money and we're great
sports down with all the facilities
pretty much done so it seemed like a
no-brainer for us to go to the Olympics
and say just like we did in 84 it's time
to reboot the brand come to LA we'll
reconnect you with a new generation of
sports fans and of sports and you know
after four years we got it and you know
for the first time coming back since
1996 at the Summer Games United States
Boston of course punted on the Olympics
they didn't want it after they were
named as the US Representative for the
2024 Olympics have you noted over the
last you know four eight years whatever
timetable that interest in hosting the
Olympics has kind of waned globally
absolutely I mean founded Boston Park
Hamburg Germany dropped out Rome Italy
Budapest Hungary so it was down to just
Paris and us and this is a great way
that we both can win Paris will take 24
will take 28 but we'll get hundreds of
millions of dollars more for waiting and
you know that's what my pitch to the
Olympics was this is kind of yearly like
the mid seventies remember 1977 we did
it was right after the Montreal Olympics
were you know that said he went way into
debt to build new facilities that
weren't used afterwards as extensively
as they thought and so actually no other
city in the world was around at the end
that we got to 84 Olympics but after la
showed how to do it with Peter Ueberroth
and changing the sponsorship model in
1985 six cities bid in Barcelona won for
their 92 Olympics so I think the same
thing will happen after la people will
see oh you know you don't have to kill
yourself you can use existing
infrastructure don't try to build a
bunch of vampy for using you see
say for instance for our athletes
village which saved us probably a couple
billion dollars we're using the RAM
Stadium instead of you know building a
new Olympic Stadium which saves us
probably two or three billion dollars so
these are there's a smarter way we hope
to because I love the Olympics this town
loves the Olympics but eighty to ninety
percent of people support this in
different polls so it's time to help the
Olympics come back and get back to its
roots which is about sports and
competition when Boston was awarded the
Olympics locals the media they pretty
much universally panned it and and
didn't want it what has been the
reaction of your constituents the people
of LA to your bid and ultimately your
awarding of the Olympics it is it's such
overwhelming support I mean I think with
our lowest poll was 78 percent the
highest has been 88% one that just came
out last week by the local university
showed 83 percent support I mean in a
big city that means you can sign
hundreds of thousands of people against
it but there's millions of people for it
because you know so many people
volunteered so many people went to those
events even some people who don't care
for sports remember there was no traffic
in LA for 17 days and 84 so some of them
come up to me saying hey mayor we throw
the Olympics just so I can get 17 days
with no traffic back here in LA so it's
an amazing things that I think brings us
together and the real legacy of this
will not be a bunch of buildings it will
be we're going to make sports
universally accessible to all kids in
all zip codes so no family has to stress
out about $150 for a uniform that they
can't afford so their kid doesn't get to
play baseball or basketball and that
legacy won't have to wait till after the
Olympics our negotiations for 28 games
enough money to start that as year early
as next year in the lead up and then
permanently after how Bad's trap are
going to be in the build-up to the
Olympics though you know traffic is
always bad in Los Angeles but voters in
November passed the biggest initiative
in this nation's history times to we're
building 15 new light rail lines and
rapid transit lines fixing our freeways
I mean LA is a place people wanna be so
traffic's always going to be a little
bit tough but you know I joke that it's
not just the Olympics it's a Jewish
holiday or Farmageddon enough people get
off the road here about 10 percent and
the traffic actually flows so we hope to
see a lot
stuff open by 2028 the new lines
certainly where the villages at UCLA
will have a subway that can move faster
than a car even when there's no traffic
on the west side of LA all the way to
downtown where a lot of those events are
going to be at USC and and down by the
Staples Center well the Olympics be
spread out over areas outside of Los
Angeles how far outside of the greater
LA area do you expect to go there's a
couple of things outside of LA but
supposed to clustered for Olympic parks
which will allow you to see multiple
sports without having to go in and out
of security you can see probably no
fencing right next to basketball and
still stay in the same secured area
downtown down by the StubHub Center and
Carson can check out multiple sports
some tennis to rugby and other things
that will be in the same campus the only
ones outside the LA area is right now we
have volleyball wanted to be down in
where the Ducks played the Honda Center
in Anaheim because that's kind of the
center of basketball globally i sorry
volleyball globally and then our rowing
you don't have a lot of water so right
now we're a little bit east of LA and
the lake a place called Lake Paris but
we're also talking about possibly doing
in Long Beach we're going to have four
or five different sports already so
it'll be pretty compact once you get
into an Olympic Park and the nice thing
that's different than other Olympics you
know even when they're closer together
you got to go in and out of security not
going to take hours once you get in here
you might catch three or four sports and
any one of these parks before let you go
as we talked about the Olympics the
interest in hosting
Summer Games Winter Games has waned kind
of globally do you think the Olympics
should continue to rotate cities every
four years or would it benefit from
having a fixed location for summer and
winter games you know I'm open to both
and LA would be a natural place to have
you know every four Olympics come here
we're ready we could I said you know 30
minutes probably two months from now or
two decades from now but that said I
hope that LA inspires cities that might
think I can't do this that you can fit
your city to the Olympics
rather than having Olympics having to
fit into your city so to me you know
there's plenty of places that have
plenty of facilities if we would just
get over the oh I have to have 15
people watch team handball or whatever
it is you know you can have two or three
thousand in a great arena that probably
exists in American cities and anyone
have to build things same thing around
the world so I think the Olympics can be
a little bit more accommodating realize
that the real audience is the TV
audience and you can have a great
smaller venue we could still keep going
to new cities but if they decide to just
go to some set ones la would be at the
top of that list well congratulations
mr. mayor on the Olympics 2028 best of
luck in preparing for it and thanks for
joining me here on the show thanks man
really appreciate it good talking to
Matt Eric Garcetti the mayor of Los
Angeles joining me here dan Patrick Sean
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience